"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
THE PRESIDENT'S SON IS ONE STEP
AWAY FROM SERIOUS LEGAL
TROUBLES.
FEDERAL AGENTS INVESTIGATING
HUNTER BIDEN REPORTEDLY THINK
THEY HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
CHARGE HIM WITH TAX CRIMES AND
FOR LYING ABOUT HIS DRUG USE ON
A FEDERAL GUN FORM.
THE LEGAL FATE OF THE FIRST SON
NOW IN THE HANDS OF A >> Dana:
TRUMP-APPOINTED U.S. ATTORNEY IN
DELAWARE.
FEDS APPEARED TO BE CLOSING AND
AFTER A 4-YEAR INVESTIGATION,
WHICH STARTED OVER
HUNTER BIDEN'S FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAWYERS NOT
DENYING THE STORY, AND INSTEAD,
TAKING ISSUE ON THE LEAK, SAYING
THIS, IT IS A FEDERAL FELONY FOR
A FEDERAL AGENT TO LEAK
INFORMATION ABOUT A GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATION SUCH AS THIS ONE.
ANY AGENT YOU CITE AS A SOURCE
IN YOUR ARTICLE HAS A FAIRLY
COMMITTED SUCH FELONY.
WE EXPECT THAT AFFIRMATIVE
JUSTICE WILL DILIGENTLY
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE SUCH
BAD ACTORS.
JUDGE, TAKE US THROUGH IT, WHAT
IS GOING ON?
>> Jeanine: OH, I LOVE IT,
THEY WANT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO DILIGENTLY
INVESTIGATE THAT LEAK, GEE, WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE LEAK OF THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION, THE
DOBBS DECISION?
I'VE NOT HEARD A WORD ABOUT
THAT.
OKAY, LET'S GET BACK TO WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE WITH
HUNTER BIDEN.
THEY STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION
IN 2018.
IT HAS BEEN FOR YEARS.
THE GRAND JURY CONCLUDED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SUMMER.
DID THEY GO TO TRUE BILL OR DID
THEY NOT GO TO TRUE BILL?
IS THERE AN INDICTMENT OR NOT AN
INDICTMENT?
IN ORDER TO INDICT SOMEONE LIKE
THE SON OF A PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE
TO GET THE PERMISSION OF THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THAT IS LISA MONACO, I
UNDERSTAND, AND MERRICK GARLAND,
EVERYBODY, DON'T LET ANYBODY
FOOL YOU, THERE IS NO WALL
THERE, MERRICK GARLAND IS MAKING
THE CALL HERE.
SO THEY NEED THAT DECISION.
IF THEY ALREADY GOT THE
INDICTMENT THAT ALL THEY NEED IS
FOR THE DEPUTY AG, THE DAG, TO
SAY OKAY, GO WITH THAT, BUT THEN
WE ARE WITHIN 60-90 DAYS OF AN
ELECTION AND YOU ARE REALLY NOT
SUPPOSED TO INDICT ANYONE WHERE
IT MIGHT IMPACT AN ELECTION.
SURE, HE IS NOT THE CANDIDATE,
BUT HE IS THE SON OF A
CANDIDATE, SO THAT WOULD APPLY,
AS WELL.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT INVITING
HIM ON TAX CRIMES AND MAKING A
FALSE STATEMENT.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
NUMBER ONE, LYING ON THAT
APPLICATION FOR THE PISTOL
PERMIT, THAT IS A GIVEN, THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY A GIVEN.
WHAT ABOUT CRIMINAL POSSESSION
OF A WEAPON?
WE HAVE ENOUGH PICTURES OF HIM
POSSESSION THAT WEBBING WHILE HE
IS IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
CLOSED AND NOT CLOTHED, SO WE
HAVE A FEW MORE CHARGES, TAX
CRIMES, PLURAL, HOPEFULLY, WHAT
ABOUT AGENT REGISTRATION ACT?
THIS KID WAS GOING THROUGH
EUROPE WITH A VACUUM CLEANER
SUCKING UP MONEY IN A PAY TO
PLAY FOR THE UNITED STATES AND
JOE, OF COURSE, IS THE BIG GUY
THAT TONY BOBULINSKI HAS COME
OUT AND SAID, GEE, THE FEDS CAME
AND TALKED TO ME BUT THEY NEVER
CAME BACK.
NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT,
IF THEY DIDN'T VOTE THAT
INDICTMENT YET AND THEY HAVE TO
GET PERMISSION, THEY CAN BRING
BACK ANOTHER GRAND JURY OR BRING
THIS GRAND JURY BACK IN.
BUT HIS ATTORNEY SAYS, WELL,
EVEN THOUGH THE FEDERAL AGENTS
SAY THEY HAVE ENOUGH, IT IS NOT
JUST A FEDERAL AGENT TO DECIDE.
WELL, GEE, THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED
WITH HILLARY CLINTON, ISN'T IT?
BUT HERE WE HAVE GOT THEM SAYING
THAT THE EVIDENCE IS BEING
PROVIDED BY THE DEFENSE THAT
SHOULD BE INCLUDED, AS WELL.
WHAT IS THIS, A TRIAL OR A GRAND
JURY?
YOU INDICT BASED UPON EVIDENCE,
YOU GO FORWARD.
DON'T TALK TO ME ABOUT DEFENSE
EVIDENCE.
AND FINALLY, WHAT ABOUT THIS --
WHO SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY
TALKED ABOUT SUPPRESSING
EVIDENCE, THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS
CAME OUT AND SAID THEY ENDED
THAT INVESTIGATION.
SO YOU HAVE ALL KINDS OF OTHER
CHARGES.
THE TIMING IS VERY UNUSUAL.
IS ANYONE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
PAINTINGS, WHETHER OR NOT THAT
WAS A PROBLEM?
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
LOOKED INTO.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO THIS THAN
JUST A TAX CHARGE AND A LINE ON
AN APPLICATION.
>> Dana: YOU MENTIONED TONY
BOBULINSKI, HE WAS ON TUCKER'S
SHOW THIS WEEK, TALKING WHAT HIS
INTERACTIONS, LET'S LOOK AT THA.
>> WOULD YOU SPEAK TO THE FBI
AGAIN?
>> I WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
>> AT ANY TIME?
>> NOT JUST THE FBI, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY, THESE FACTS ARE
EXTENSIVE, WELL-DOCUMENTED,
EASILY VERIFIED, METADATA,
MULTIPLE SOURCES SAYING THE SAME
THING, ZERO CHANCE THAT THIS HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA OR
DISINFORMATION.
>> SO WE HAVE HEARD REPEATEDLY
ACCOUNTS THERE IS OR WAS A GRAND
JURY, JURY IMPANELED IN
DELAWARE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> UM, ONE THING, I HAVE NOT
BEEN CALLED IN FRONT OF THEM.
>> Jeanine: THAT'S AMAZING.
>> Dana: RIGHT?
I WAS GOING TO ASK, HERE YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY, HAS A LOT OF
INFORMATION, HE WAS WILLING TO
TALK TO THEM, AND THEY DIDN'T
EVEN CALL THEM.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE TRYING TO
CONTAIN IT BUT YOU CAN'T CONTAIN
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE BIDEN
FAMILY, IT IS JUST TOO BIG AND
THERE IS NO COINCIDENCE THIS
REPORT COMES OUT, DAYS AFTER
TONY B GOES ON TUCKER CARLSON
AND BLOWS THE WHOLE THING WIDE
OPEN AGAIN.
MY SOURCE TELLS ME THAT
HUNTER BIDEN REJECTED A PRETTY
SWEET PLEA DEAL, AND THEY WERE
GOING TO HAVE HIM FLEE, NO
PRISON TIME, A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FINES, AND HE
TURNED IT DOWN.
THAT WAS A BAD IDEA, BECAUSE NOW
I AM HEARING IS ABOUT
$15 MILLION IN FINES AND THEY
ARE THROWING MORE FELONIES THAT
HE HAS TO PLEAD TO.
WE ARE HEARING ABOUT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS THAT ARE COMING
OUT IN THE FBI.
WE ARE HEARING ABOUT POSSIBLE
MORE WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
WHO KNOW AND HAVE DONE BUSINESS
WITH THE BIDEN FAMILY, POSSIBLY
COMING OUT, PUBLICLY.
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
HOUSE, WHO IS IT GOING TO BECOME
A JIM JORDAN, ONE OF THESE GUYS
IS GOING TO HAVE THE GAVEL, AND
THEY ARE GOING TO BE CALLING
ASSOCIATES OF THE BIDEN FAMILY
TO TESTIFY.
ALL UNDER OATH ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
THEY WILL BE SUBPOENAING
TREASURY RECORDS THAT SHOW THESE
SUSPICIOUS WIRE TRANSFERS FROM
CHINA AND RUSSIA AND GOD KNOWS
WHERE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
STOP THAT.
CNN, MSNBC, THEY HAVE NOT SEEN
THIS EVIDENCE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TONY B,
MORE PEOPLE COMING OUT UNDER
OATH, ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THIS IS NOT A HUNTER BIDEN
STORY, THIS IS A JOE BIDEN STOR.
THE HOUSE OF CARDS COULD FALL IF
THEY KEEP THE PRESSURE ON.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE EVIDENCE TO
WHERE THIS IS GOING, JOE BIDEN
IS A TRAITOR, BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
WAS GOING TO BE THE FRONT MAN
FOR CHINA'S ROAD INITIATIVE.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE THE
UNITED STATES SUPREMACY WE HAVE
EVER HAD.
THIS IS THEIR IMPERIAL
COMMERCIAL STRATEGY TO SUPPLANT
THE UNITED STATES AS THE NUMBER
ONE WORLD POWER.
THEY WERE PAYING THE BIDEN
FAMILY TO BE THE AMERICAN FACE
OF THE CHINESE BELT AND RODE.
AND BIDEN WAS GETTING PAID TO DO
THAT.
I HAVE NO -- I DON'T SEE HOW YOU
CAN KEEP THIS UNDER WRAPS FOR
THAT MUCH LONGER.
THIS MIGHT BE THE PERFECT EXCUSE
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO SAY HEY,
JOE, WE DON'T WANT YOU TO RUN
ANYMORE.
HERE IS A GOOD EXCUSE WHY YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY SAY ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
ABOUT TRUMP, ON THE MAR-A-LAGO
RAID, NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
WELL, DOES THAT WORK THIS WAY,
TOO?
>> Greg: GOD, I WISH I HAD
LIKE HUNTERS POWER.
NOBODY I KNOW COULD GET AWAY
WITH ALL OF THIS FOR SO LONG.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE FACT,
MAYBE THIS IS GOOD FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, IF YOU WERE TO REPORT
ANY OF THIS STUFF PRIOR TO THE
2020 ELECTION YOU WOULD HAVE
BEEN BANNED FROM SOCIAL MEDIA,
OSTRACIZED BY ALL OF THE
SMARTY-PANTS IN THE MEDIA.
BUT NOW IT'S OKAY, RIGHT?
AND I THINK IT IS BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE THE CALL TO BURY THIS
STORY WORKED, THEY GOT JOE
ELECTED, AND NOW THEY CAN USE
THIS STORY TO BURY JOE, SO I
DON'T THINK -- THERE ISN'T AN
URGENCY OR RUSH TO STOP THIS
STORY BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT, IF
IT DOES THE WORK THAT THEY
WANTED TO DO, WHICH IS TO GET
JOE OFF THE STAGE, THAN ACTUALLY
IT IS GOING TO WORK FOR THEM.
I THINK, HOWEVER, BEFORE WE
DISCUSS ANYMORE OF THIS THIS WE
SHOULD RUN IT BY THE 50
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY TO FIND OUT
IF THIS IS MORE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
IT'S WEIRD.
FOR ME, I AM SO JADED BY THE
HUNTER BIDEN STUFF THAT I CAN'T
EVEN TELL WHAT'S A BIG DEAL
ANYMORE.
LIKE, IS THIS THE BIG DEAL, IS
IT NOT THE BIG DEAL?
I THINK THAT IS ANOTHER SUCCESS
OF THE MEDIA, IS THAT IF THE
BIDEN STUFF I'D COME OUT IN ONE
BIG CHUNK, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
STAGGERING BEYOND ANY
SCANDAL.
THAT COLLUSION, THE INFLUENCE
PEDDLING, THE DRUGS, THE
HOOKERS, THE GUNS, IT'S A
MASSIVE STORY.
BUT IT KIND OF DRIPPED, DRIPPED
OUT, IT WAS DILUTED BY TIME.
SO NOW IT IS KIND OF LIKE A
DAILY COMIC STRIP.
IT IS LIKE OH, YEAH, THAT GUY.
WE DON'T EVEN REPORT ON IT AS
MUCH, BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IF
CONGRESS IS WON BY THE
REPUBLICANS, THEY DEFINITELY,
DEFINITELY HAVE TO DO HEARING
SPIRITS BEFORE AND I BET THEY
CALL OF THOSE INTEL PEOPLE --
>> Greg: ONE BY ONE.
>> Dana: HERALD, THE LAST WORD
CAN HAVE THE FLOOR.
>> Harold: SO THE REPORTING IS
ACCURATE, WHICH YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE A LOT OF THIS IS,
PARTICULARLY OF HUNTER'S LAWYERS
HAVE NOT INTERFERED OR NOT
RESPONDED.
SOUNDS LIKE HUNTER BIDEN WILL BE
SUBJECTED TO THE AMERICAN LEGAL
PROCESS.
HE KNOWS AS WELL AS ANYONE, HE
IS A GRADUATE OF ONE OF THE
GREAT LAW SCHOOLS IN THIS
COUNTRY, YALE LAW SCHOOL, NO ONE
IS ABOVE THE LAW, HE WILL HAVE
TO FACE WHATEVER IT IS HE HAS TO
FACE.
I DON'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT TO SAY
OTHER THAN THE REPORTING IS WHAT
IT IS.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID, THIS
INVESTIGATION UNDER HIM STARTED
I BELIEVE UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND NOW IT LOOKS AS IF THEY MAY
HAVE CONCLUDED IN AN INDICTMENT.
I SAY ONE LESS THING, I DON'T
TAKE ANY GLEE IN ANY ONE WHO HAS
MISFORTUNE WHO OR WHO HAS A
FAULT.
HE HAS WRITTEN ABOUT THIS
EPISODE IN HIS LIFE, TALKED
ABOUT THE ADDICTIONS, THE DRUGS,
THE ALCOHOL, I AM BLESSED TO
HAVE NOT HAD THOSE ADDICTIONS,
WE ARE ALL BLESSED TO NOT HAVE
THOSE KIND OF ADDICTIONS.
THAT IS NO EXCUSE, BUT I WISH
HIM AND HIS FAMILY THE BEST AND
HE WILL HAVE TO FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> Jeanine: I WANT TO SAY ONE
MORE THING, IT IS CLEARLY NO
EXCUSE AND NO DEFENSE BUT LET ME
MAKE ONE THING PERFECTLY CLEAR.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
WHO HAVE SERVED TIME IN FEDERAL
PRISON WHEN THEY HAVE ACTUALLY
PAID THEIR TAXES BACK, AND THE
FACT THAT THIS MAN WAS OFFERED A
PLEA BARGAIN WITH